playing zelda games is great but have
you ever wanted to be linked finding
items and solving puzzles I'm Tony and
this is your real world gamespot news
update Nintendo is teaming up with
escape room company scrap for defenders
of the Triforce a zelda themed
experience rather than challenging you
to escape a locked room defenders of the
Triforce challenges six people to solve
puzzles and a quote huge area the
experience will involve items and races
from the game including the Goron Zora &
Co Kyrie tribes defenders of the
Triforce is coming to eight different US
cities and 2017 starting with San
Francisco from january thirty first
through februari fifth you can check out
the rest of the stops over at games 5 in
other Zelda news the next game breath of
the wild may not be released alongside
the Nintendo switched this March but
don't be surprised to hear more about it
during Nintendo's presentation on
January 12th to keep up with all the
latest video game news in the real world
and on consoles you're already in the
right place